in this video i want to give you a very
brief overview of dred scott vs sanford
a supreme court decision made in 1857
that had major consequences on the
definition of citizenship in the united
states
this case was tied up with so many of
the questions and problems that plagued
america at this time particularly
slavery and the westward expansion of
the nation that it's really easy to go
far down into the rabbit hole on this
one but i'm going to try to restrain
myself and just give you the basics you
need to know to understand what happened
in the case and why it's important if
you do want to learn more about the dred
scott case we have a much more in-depth
video on the subject that i'll link to
in the description
okay so let me set the scene for you in
the mid-1800s
the us government had been trying to
balance the desires and the political
power of the slave-owning southern
states and the free northern states for
decades
they kept making compromises to keep the
union from falling apart and one of
these was the missouri compromise of
1820 the geography of this is important
so let's take a look at a map of north
america at the time
so here you can see the free states and
territories of the north in green
and the slave owning states and
territories in blue in 1820 the us
government agreed that to maintain the
balance of power between slave and free
states as new states entered the union
from western lands new states below this
3630 line of latitude would be slave
states and above it would be free states
missouri was the exception the last
slave state to be admitted above that
line now this compromise worked to stave
off political disunion for 30 years but
by the 1850s when a whole bunch of new
states were set to enter the union
following mexico's session of this land
to the united states the compromise was
starting to fall apart now what does all
this have to do with a man named dred
scott dredd was an enslaved man who had
been born into slavery in virginia his
enslaver eventually moved to missouri
and when dredd was about 30 years old
that man sold him to an army doctor
named emerson emerson took dread to
illinois
where dredd married his wife harriet who
was also enslaved emerson went back to
missouri but left dredd and harriet in
illinois he sold their services as
laborers and kept the money that they
made which was definitely illegal
because he was practicing slavery in a
free state after a year or so emerson
moved to louisiana and married a woman
named eliza sanford and emerson ordered
dread and harriet to join them they took
a steamboat down to louisiana and while
they were on that steamboat harriet gave
birth to a baby girl who was lawfully
free since she had been born in free
territory but the emersons continued to
enslave all three of them
eventually dr emerson died and his wife
eliza sanford became the sole owner of
the scott family who had moved back to
missouri with her in 1846 dredd tried to
purchase their freedom from her but she
refused so he filed a freedom suit in
missouri court he pled that since he had
been taken into a free state he should
have been freed and that his family was
being held unjustly the case made its
way through the courts over the course
of several years and in the meantime
eliza transferred ownership of the scots
to her brother john sanford since he
lived in a different state it became a
federal case and eventually it came
before the supreme court
so in 1857 the supreme court led at that
time by chief justice roger tawny issued
its ruling in dred scott vs sanford
you'll notice that sanford has an extra
d in it in the title because it was
entered incorrectly in the records and
never changed
tawny wrote the majority opinion and he
came to two main conclusions first that
dred scott couldn't bring suit in the
supreme court because he was black and
the descendant of enslaved africans
tawny said that he believed the founders
of the united states had never intended
for black people enslaved or free to
have citizenship rights he made a
distinction between black people who he
believed the founders intended for
perpetual servitude and indigenous
people who he thought had been treated
as members of separate nations and
therefore could immigrate to the united
states if they wanted to what does this
tell you about how tawny was envisioning
citizenship and who was eligible to
claim it
now generally in cases when the supreme
court rules that it doesn't have
jurisdiction to hear a case it stops
there it doesn't go on to give any
opinion about the merits of the case
itself but tony bucked that convention
and went on to make a ruling about
whether going over that missouri
compromise line from a slave state to a
free one made dred scott free and he
said that it didn't and that the whole
missouri compromise was unconstitutional
because it interfered with slave owners
property rights now it's worth
mentioning here that the dred scott
decision is
universally regarded as the worst
supreme court decision of all time not
just because it was morally bankrupt but
also because it wasn't based on sound
reasoning
tawny definitely cherry-picked his
evidence about the founders never
intending black people to be citizens
for example he left out the fact that
propertied black men could vote in five
of the original 13 states at the time of
the founding and that the founders
agreed to outlaw slavery in the
northwest territory both of which
suggest that there wasn't any kind of
consensus among the founders about the
status of black people or the future of
slavery in the west so what was the
impact of this decision the supreme
court thought that this decision was
going to settle the question about
slavery and it spread to the west for
good but it ended up completely
backfiring tensions between the north
and south started to reach a fever pitch
after this decision abraham lincoln
started to gain a national following
because of his arguments against this
case and eventually civil war would
erupt when lincoln became president
after the civil war two new amendments
to the constitution would undo the dred
scott decision the 13th amendment which
abolished slavery and the 14th amendment
which guaranteed citizenship rights for
all people born in the united states
although dred scott lost his case just
two months later he did get his freedom
he didn't get to enjoy it for long
though since he died just a year later
his wife harriet and two daughters did
survive to see the end of slavery and
the 14th amendment
and his great-great-grandchildren are
alive today